ça ne peut énerver personne qu'une jeune
femme se présente et un enfant par
contre techniquement c'est un peu
compliqué parce que lorsqu'on est miss
france pendant l'année déjà si on est
une fille d'une d'une région on doit
aller habiter à paris donc ça déjà voilà
c'est une chose et ensuite on fait des
horaires de fou donc ça commence mal
auteur ensuite on finit avec les
galeries cafés
du lundi au dimanche toi y'a pas de
week-end mais il ya des moments magiques
n ya pas de week
end et maman solo du moment avec des
marseillais qui débarquent on récompense
s'élève à 4 heures du matin
parce que c'est mr moi j'ai été miss
france en
2002 les régions s'étaient alors
que la charente du papier lui
et moi je moi je veux vous dire que j'en
ai chié des bulletins vraiment malakal à
kaka qui s'y colle et de beauté
américaine
bien sûr qu'il ya des femmes qui sont
très occupés mais elle s'en occuper
c'est pour gagner leur vie on n'est pas
obligé de se présenter aux toilettes
aussi on ne sait pas raisonnable
non mais tant mieux si tu avais si tu
vas me sens merde
on à l'extrait de barrez vagal en choeur
qui est énervé on l'a pas il faut se
mettre mon oreiller de bordel on l'a ou
pas on n'a rien
10 alors oui je sais très bien mareva
galanter a dit une miss france n'a pas
de week-end ni de jour férié et à une
vie consacrée à son titre en 2005 oui on
fait pour elle ça n'est pas compatible
c'est ce qu'a dit delphine en fait c est
fait tout le business la même chose
toutes les miss aussi perdre leur chéri
pendant l'année parce que complètement
on peut pas tenir une rotule a pas perdu
tout en maintenant je suis là toute sa
perte était déjà avec eux roger avec des
gens bien non j'avais mon premier chérie
avec kiwi auquel je suis resté dedans
il ya cinq ans après miss france
pmf france et saliha miss france sont
maintenant
très connu
elle a perdu gros
elle a perdu à rennes mais a perdu gros
du rocher à l'inconnu roger il n'a pas
réapparu comme la dame blanche
sur une route c'est vrai oui géraldine
ton avis moi j'aime beaucoup non ma miss
france parce que je trouve que alors
peut-être que vous n'êtes pas
représentatif ici on n'est peut-être pas
mais il ya bien un nom mais les produits
mais il ya plein de gens qui regardent
sur m'intéresse de savoir qui est une
terrine sort ne serait il regarde et je
m'en bats les steaks et franchement
grâce à sylvie tellier suu kyi a uriné
vous aimez chez nous éclaire l art et
shell sont hyper moderne aujourd'hui
quand on suit les installe par exemple
d'amandine ou de diane c'est passionnant
ils sont super drôles elles ont beaucoup
d'humour beaucoup de dérision à raconter
vraiment leur vie et c'est vachement
intéressant pour les jeunes femmes par
exemple qu'ils veulent voilà qui
s'intéressent à elle et moi je trouve
que c'est très bien parce que petit à
petit à des évolutions de critères qui
sont pas dingue mais je trouve que c'est
bien d'être une liste maman et pourquoi
pas même si on voit pas s'énerver il ya
plein de mamans qui va mois leurs
enfants tout le temps et qui bossent ya
matsushita m moi tu mon nom mais je sais
que c'est que de la com ils savent plus
quoi faire pour modern folks concours
miss france qui a une image sexiste et
ringarde il ya tellement dû ramer dur
qui était exclue du concours presque
toutes les femmes en fait il fallait pas
être il fallait être célibataire ne pas
avoir d'enfant ne pas être trop bon
arrêtez moi je pense que sylvie tellier
c'était la gardienne du temple voilà etc
est au contraire avancée très bien quand
il y avait des règles des trucs là ça
part en cacahuète total ça va être
n'importe quoi moi ça y est ils m'ont
guimond perdu la mission et on en est à
se réjouir on en est à se réjouir qu'ils
acceptent les femmes âme en importe quoi
l'année ces hypocrites ils ont dû rester
comme avant puis c'est tout c'est
hypocrite donc ils enlevaient halimi
doit pas enlever à la limite de taille
parce qu'ils pensent que pour les agents
de domaine
la raison dans ce cas là tu prends tout
le monde voit l'arrivée vous présentez
arrêté je suis fier tout le monde hélène
gaubert radical accepter aux étranges
tout le monde avait pas avait pas eu ma
nature moins d'un mètre soixante dix et
non à la une face père presse à un
porte-manteau day avec un rayon sur
wii est où il ya des critères oui on a
concouru une soirée bien sûr l arrivée
je peux pas dire quand tu peux pas dire
pour l'oseille j'ai pas je n'accepte pas
des meubles d'un mètre 70 mais je veux
bien une maman où je veux bien arrêter
les mecs si on dit ben alors voilà bah
le concours maintenant belle manière à
tout le monde et il n'y a plus de voix
ya plus de différence de taille voilà il
ya plus bas on fait avec ce qu'on peut
tenir là c'est n'importe quoi moins d'un
mètre soixante dix tu peux pas parce
qu'après derrière pour les agences de
mannequins oui mais arrêter ben c'est
quoi les critères maintenant les
critères
70 euros départ attaque en tunisie
seront sous-représentés général entre
alors dans tout ça non mais alors pas
donc c'est cool c'est d'oser
ce cas là dessus dit bah c'est ouvert à
tout le monde je suis désolé mais si tu
commentes a changé il est maman et les
trucs
mais
maman quand on est mannequin ça empêche
pas de faire du business en revanche sur
fait mais ce sont deux ça empêche
on et de l'hypocrisie est exactement
france ça doit être la femme kate qui
représente la france et qu'ils
considéraient comme la plus belle par
les français et la plus simple à douala
et amandine elles font plus damas tandis
et
bah oui mais à maxime pourquoi
maintenant tu dis pas une mince d'un
mètre 60 5 ou 1 m 60 des pétitions se
plaira aux
téléspectateurs des fonds c'est que
votre moral plus belle quand le business
commence à faire que moi je suis pour
les ouvertures mist rangeant des femmes
mamans tout ça sur lui mais on regarde
le seul critère qui peut tuer le
business exactement c'est à dire que moi
même puis a forcé d'un coup mais laissez
moi finir arrêté c'est quoi ces deux là
soient cohérentes
et vous avez proférer des insanités
débile ses limites les sépare les
laisser parler les gens pensaient
proférer des insanités genou vous êtes
dans le business jeunes filles obèses
c'est exactement seul l'argent compte
pour vous c'est à dire que oui alors
qu'il y faire des sources tout ce que tu
veux tu peux faire sans les femmes oui
mais voilà
les jaunes avec 70 n'avait pas fondre
ses bonnes qu'on entend monnaie mais oui
mais alors taisez vous que je puisse
finir
sans levier d'un mètre 70 ya pas de
business lab agence de mannequins n'y a
pas de concours international anglais
intéresse personnage du coup maintient
son sacre hyper donc les ou même sur ces
bidons on ouvre tout ce que les sens
mais tant que ça sente pas le business
je dois hypocrisie du buzz honnêtement
et voilà vous êtes dur nas et comprendre
et du boeuf attendrait du bugue et soi
disant progressistes va excusez du peu
on a des critères qui tombe qui sont des
critères pourquoi une meuf de dre
discriminant qui me semblait la taille
et la taille pourquoi une femme de moins
de médecine ne peut pas être mises
d'accord
je me mets donc maison pas donc je suis
donc miss france on pour être miss ronde
il faut qu'on soit grande pour
représenter les fronts s'est fait
remettre dedans mais de son lycée
ouais la relève est assurée mais ça mais
ce sont deux choses sont elles
représentent pas la face à la
france
qu'ils veulent maintenant aujourd'hui on
veut des mamans voeu de tous aujourd'hui
à la touvre à tour élite là évidemment
il faut faire un pas vers quoi ils
pouvaient être différent mais en quoi ça
vous gêne que cette barrière là le fait
qu'elle soit maman partout
comme en orient métaux qui sont lightin
dérange pas qu'on est malade deux fois à
montréal et pas du tout du tout genre
lisent comme des prodigy cependant à ma
porte et mannequin ça mais j'avais
l'impression d'être revu un objet ou
instrumentalisées tu fais ce que tu veux
on fait la leçon pendant un an les
balades et aurait à dire
les objets en quoi des finales était une
femme objet cantat et emma daumas
l'actif et
[Rires]
delphine appliquée mais moi je vous dis
je vais clôturer ce que je pense et je
redonnerai la parole à guillaume qui est
un ami avait dans la vérité bah oui
c'est un ami et miss france chez audi et
sur les réseaux tout le monde me chaut
jure tout le monde dit d'accord on
s'ouvre à tout le monde mais si on ouvre
à tout le monde on ouvre à tout va et on
enlève le critère de la taille a dit
je suis désolée elle a dit à daniel est
le concours élite y un concours de
mannequin le fonds comme miss france ça
n'a rien à voir donc moi je suis pour
ouvrir à tout le monde aux les mamans
tout à l'heure que j'ai le visage
mais l'important
vous a toujours raison tu es comme les
100 m soit ils représentent toutes les
femmes de france où elle représente un
seul stéréotypes bien sûr mais là il
faut arrêter d'être hypocrite c'est
juste pour faire de la com et de la com
positif parce que miss france il faisait
toujours des buzz négatif là ils
essayent de chant de change et se
redonner une bonne image en faisant des
buzz positif mais ils s'en foutent
complètement voilà et à ce moment là
qu'ils ne mettent pas de critère de
taille ni de poids c'est pareil c'est
peut-être cela il ya plein de fast géré
par percer leur français
y'a des jeunes femmes qui sont dit
qu'ils n'ont pas les critères de miss
france qui sont magnifiques mais bien en
france voilà donc bah voilà le concours
et même si on veut des mannequins que tu
fais toi
bon bah si toi maintenant que tu es là
on va voir ce temps pensé
téléspectateurs comme moi oui no 1 66%
non à 33 pour
savoir comment ce qu'on dit on à dire ou
non oui mais il faut tout changer oui je
pose la question
dit oui voilà dit nouba voilà un
sujet bien son but à la demi-heure tu
vois j'ai pu être maîtrisé dans ce
terrible j'ai tous les titres
mais antoine est rationnel et de tous
les de tous les temps mais quand il ya
un concours excusez-moi j'ai fait plus
que tu mets le d r d sont 65 10 élus 42
cocetta les digues les avait fait des
catcheurs mirage aux paramètres 80 pas
dans quel temps merde voilà
ce que les râteliers en ressortir oui si
on enlève tous les critères comme des
généralistes si on enlève tous les
critères de beauté qui sont parfois très
exclusive puis la mettre 70 c'est rare
pour une femme si on enlève tous les
critères de beauté alors tout le monde
est beau alors toutes les femmes
tombaient comme des lâches en deux
parties très bon tu présentes s'étaient
c'était frank michael
je suis désolé sinon on sera tous
mannequin on s'est tous en une de
magazines à un concours de mannequin
les rennais daniel la plus belle alors
il intelligent rien avec ddv d'éventuels
ils n'ont rien on élit la plus belle
femme était la piste la
plus sympathique ces cinq années il
pourra alors tiré la veille lors des
séries et chaque année quand on est ici
on reçoit reçoit toutes les miss c'est
vous nous dites laquelle est la plus
belle pour vous on arrive dans
l'émission et on doit de vous dire la
caméra filmait des
attractions les entends parler que
pierre manent c'est à ce moment là que
ça joue jeudi contre la baisse il faut
que ça cesse
avec son esprit de répartie
très bonne et qu'elle donnait truc à
l'évidence bien sûr que c'est très long
mais il faut ouvrir il faut ouvrir oui
oui c'est censé élire la plus belle
femme de france et quand on lit le
règlement en fait c'est exclu toutes les
femmes et les enfants nés entre le 1er
janvier 96 et premier noir à avoir été
mariées ou pacsées pas sur antoine math
pire c'est une limite de poids linda
haywood ac
dc des critères c'est à géométrie
variable parce qu'il s'en fout donner la
joie et vite d'élire une miss qui est
petit ou ronde ça les dérange pas bien
sûr il ya du bizness derrière ce que tu
as un faux cul tu voterais pour
quelqu'un 62 eur
[Musique]
pas d'entrée je vais devant une caméra
qui dit oui
regardez sont à regarder le cul voilà
merci bravo à
toi